incorporar a México Brasil y chile como
países grandes e invitar formalmente a
Estados Unidos a participar en el
proceso mediante el envío de un delegado
especial son parte de los acuerdos
anunciados este viernes por las
delegaciones del Ln y el gobierno
colombiano que recordemos se encuentran
en Caracas desde el pasado 21 de
noviembre como el reinicio formal de las
negociaciones de paz que iniciaron en el
año 2016 bajo la administración del
presidente Juan Manuel Santos en esta
oportunidad no hubo convocatoria a
prensa por lo que se limitaron a leer el
comunicado en el que también se
formaliza la incorporación del
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
mediante su delegado en Colombia y de la
conferencia episcopal colombiana como
mediadores en este proceso otro de los
puntos importantes es el que habla de
alivios humanitarios aunque no se
ofrecen detalles al respecto podría
traducirse en liberación de secuestrados
y excarcelación de guerrilleros
recordamos que ya se han adelantado
acciones en esta materia como gestos de
buena voluntad por parte de ambos estas
conversaciones continuarán hasta
mediados de diciembre según se había
anunciado en un primer comunicado